gotta ask you about the book coming out  this fall give me a tease i know you're  talking about a guy in there oh yeah i  am i'm talking about a guy are you  dating now uh I'm seeing somebody as  this this is a good thing yes it's a  nice thing and will this relationship  lined up in the book yeah and how does  he feel about it cautiously cautious I'm  actually very at today I started to get  very nervous about the book because  there may be some people who aren't  speaking to me after I put it out yikes  has from the previous two books has  there been one person that's really  comportment like Andy what the I've  wondered there have been some kind of  silent vibes that I've wondered about  we'll see worried about more a little  bit yeah